Let's go back to probability and go back to our simplest of all examples--that of a coin flip.
Assume that p is the probability that the coin comes up heads and assume we flip the coin N times--
that is the same as saying that a sample size of N.
It gives us N outcomes and in the past, we computed the empirical mean, the variance,
but now I will let you compute the confidence interval.
Let's start--I'm going to ask you a series of questions, most of them are fairly challenging,
and at the end you'll be able to compute the confidence interval for a sample size N of coin flips.
Let me begin. What is the expected mean outcome when you flip this coin?
Suppose one is heads, 0 is tails--either comes up, it's is 0.5 chance.
This could be a number where the number scales between 0 and 1.
It would be 0 if the expected outcome is always tails and be 1 if the expected outcome is always heads.